les Russes incontestablement sur
certainement sur décision politique
parce que militairement c'est plus
délicat ont décidé de tenir à tout prix
cette cette région autour de la ville de
Kerson j'arrive droite il y a à peu près
20000 soldats russes sur la rive gauche
et à peu près autant et
vous avez là à peu près un quart de tout
de toutes les forces russes qui sont
concentrées autour de Carson ce qui
montre bien qu'il s'agit d'une priorité
incontestable pour eux
ils tiennent la position ils tiennent la
zone parce que c'est c'est une zone qui
est plate c'est laquelle ils sont
installés depuis des mois ils ont
installé ils ont mis d'ailleurs
pratiquement leur meilleur troupes dans
dans cette région tous les villages sont
fortifiés c'est comme ces plats tout est
visible du ciel et toutes les
préparatifs d'attaques sont visibles ils
peuvent être frappés par l'artillerie
etc donc vous avez ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est le combat extrêmement
difficile pour pour les Ukrainiens mais
tendresse petit à petit en deux mois ils
ont réduit cette poche par deux et
actuellement les Russes sont en
situation où
ils ont rien capable pour impossible
pour eux de reprendre l'offensive mais
en gros soit ils tiennent ils tiennent
cette tête de pont le plus longtemps
possible en espérant que avec leur
mobilisation à partir de l'arrivée de
l'hiver puis les effets de la
mobilisation ils pourront peut-être
reprendre le dessus un peu plus tard bon
c'est peu probable malgré tout deuxième
possibilité pour eux c'est de se replier
plus ou moins de manière plus ou moins
organisée complètement de l'autre côté
du fleuve ça je pense que c'est les
militaires qui demanderaient ça parce
que pour éviter de se retrouver piégé
mais la troisième hypothèse c'est que
voilà ils vont certainement se replier
préparer une bataille de
urbaine de grande ampleur dans la ville
de Carson ils vont essayer d'en faire
une sorte de Stalingrad sur le Nieppe un
contestablement et voilà tout indique
qu'il se prépare que tout le monde en
tout cas anticipe cette cette bataille
les services craignants parlaient de
bataille dankerson pour le mois de
novembre je trouve ça peut-être un peu
optimiste mais en tout cas oui ça tout
le monde Ant